so let's now start talking about what is
the deep web because your web server can
say a few things as well as saying
here's your page it can also say I don't
know what that page is so if I say can
we go to not until I see dot uk' slash
free stuff for max it goes I'm sorry I
don't know what that is page not found
that we don't have free stuff for max it
can also say you're not allowed to go
there so we can say if I want to go to
knotting to a CD UK / HR / increase my
salary HTML it will say sorry you can't
go there that's a bit of the web you're
not allowed to see and that's really
what the Deep Web is is bits of the web
that Google is not allowed to see or
can't find or hasn't found and so the
easiest way of looking at the Deep Web
is it's just a huge portion of the web
which Google doesn't have the password
to go and see or hasn't come across yet
or is sitting unconnected to the rest of
the web somewhere the
four bits of what makes the Deep Web or
for nice examples that say what makes
the Deep Web different from the web one
is it stuff behind passwords so any
place that you go we have to type in a
password is a place that Google can't go
because it doesn't have your password so
it it can't look at your bank
information it can't look at your
profile page on Amazon or credit ek in
fact if you make your profile on
Facebook not public you've essentially
pulled your profile on Facebook down
into the Deep Web rather than having it
on the surface bit of the web but all
the normal pages like the main page of
facebook.com is on the non web the
surface web that Google can see it just
simply can't get the X it doesn't have
the pro the passwords that you have
there's also lots of dynamic content so
this is a second part content which gets
generated based on what you do or where
you are and things like that so if you
go on down and credit Kate and search
for something Google hasn't seen that
set of search results because it hasn't
typed in every single possible word you
could ever type into Amazon search so
you see the products it's found most of
the products so it's indexed all those
pages because it there's links to it on
the front page of Amazon but it hasn't
seen all the dynamic things that you
create because you typed in a word that
it hadn't thought of typing in so this
is dynamic content that it can't access
and so your Facebook feed is another
type of dynamic content which is always
changing and so it's a can't get there
because it's at the password and be last
time it looked it was different to the
time he just looked so hasn't seen it
there's also something called the robot
exclusion standard which is a nice thing
there's most web sites have a little
file which is robots.txt on the server
and that says to Google or other things
that are browsing automatically you can
look at those pages but please don't
look at those pages and Google simply
just doesn't look at them because it was
asked not to
so there's large portions that the
website designers say please don't index
this but you can look at that bit does
that just rely on trust though
yes yeah so you could write a spider
that works like Google spider which just
ignores robots.txt but you'd be somewhat
breaking the rules by doing that um is
that a legal thing or just I don't know
is there's the fair answer it could be
it could just be a politeness thing just
like most standards on the Internet and
so then therefore type of stuff that's
in the deep
it's just stuff that nobody's ever
linked to so has never been found as
this Google spiders have never followed
a link to find it and therefore it's
just it's there but Google hasn't seen
it so it's not that it's hard access
it's just so deep that nobody's found it
so my laptop has a web server on it HTTP
server and so I can host web files on my
laptop when I connected it to the
internet it got a unique address and so
people can type in that address and then
see the web pages that are on my laptop
and so technically kind of anybody could
do that and then you just tell your
friends the unique kind of code for how
to get there not the web link because
you didn't create a web link maybe and
your friends type in the 1.1 to 8.1 93.2
74 go look at your laptop and then never
tell anybody else about it cuz you're a
little secret web page for you and your
friends and so that's just a part of the
web that Google never came across and it
won't come across it until either you
tell Google about it or someone links to
it from another web page that Google
seen and so all this is deep web stuff
which is perfectly normal stuff that
Google just doesn't have access to or
hasn't found and so that's the best way
of looking at the Deep Web is just all
the parts of the web that Google can't
just walk up and see or hasn't come
visited yet and so how big as the Deep
Web is interesting question Google's
index for the normal web or the surface
web went past one trillion pages not too
long ago that was a kind of milestone it
went past so Google knows about 1
trillion pages but latest estimates of
the Deep Web that it's 95 percent
whereas the 5 percent that Google has
seen is there's 1 trillion pages so it's
much much bigger 500 times bigger and
that sort of makes sense because 95
percent of Facebook is stuff you look at
after you've logged in with your
passwords so there's only a small
portion that Google can see which is
before you log in and there's whole
websites which you just need passwords
to access forums or academic literature
or just huge resources of content that
Google doesn't go and see and so it's
very very big it's just not very scary
and not very unusual it's just behind
password
so this takes us then to what is the
dark web because we now know what the
Internet is the physical connections we
not the web is which is just software
for transferring information and we know
the deep web is which is just the bits
of the web we have seen so what is the
dark web so the best way to look at the
dark web is that it's just the web but
built differently so it's not surprising
really and then the web was just some
software that someone built and it
describes how people share information
and so you could rebuild that but
instead of saying get that page you
could have built it to say send me that
page you know it's just asked a
different question use a different code
speaking a slightly different language
and so there are several dark webs on
the Internet's they sit on the Internet
overlay the same internet like the web
does they just talk different languages
they have secret handshakes and they
encrypt things in different ways and
they store websites and different places
and you have to look at you have to go
somewhere else find out where it is and
so a good example of a dark web is tor
which is the onion web they call it then
you go to dot onion pages rather than
com pages you know it's just different
languages different codes and they the
way you ask for a page is differently so
you might type into chrome say I'd like
to see that page about horses which is
on the dark web and the dark web goes or
wood you mean get page about horses
that's not how we do things here so you
kind of have to say the Panda has orange
shoes and then suddenly it gives you
that page about horses that you wanted
it just is just talking a different
language but it's essentially
transferring pages of information like
the web does you just had to ask it the
right way so does that mean that all the
people who've got websites out they
would have to rebuild their website as
an onion type website only if you want
it to be only on the onion web so you
can be browsing the onion web using tor
which is the onion browser and that one
can look perfectly well at normal web
pages so you can go to Google on it but
it also knows how to or where to find
out where the dot onion physical
computers are and then it knows how to
ask for it and it's the other thing it
does there were somethings it sends you
on a secret stranger unusual route
with the internet to get there so if you
look at Google com on tour all I did
this morning it was in German because
the last place that I came out on the
strange secret route was in the computer
somewhere in Germany and this is sort of
why they call it the onion web because
it has many layers that you go through
so when it asks to view a webpage it
wraps up that request into several
layers of encryption and then send it to
the first computer which unlocks the
first layer and says ok thanks now I
know where to go for the second one goes
to a computer in Australia and says
unwrap the next layer and then it goes
to a computer in Germany on rats next
learn that one then asks Google comm to
see it and then it kind of gets wrapped
back up again then comes all the way
back to you which is why they call it
the onion web for the onion browser it
sounds like a kind of huge game of pass
the parcel mixed in with one of those
old 1980s films where somebody's trying
to trace it the complicated roots of a
phone call or something I'm gonna bounce
this car through nine different relay
stations throughout the world and our
two satellites it's designed to be more
anonymous and more private than what
you're doing so it's also a bit like a
secret spy who's kind of got into a
building suddenly and taking off his
coat and hat and he's wearing an apron
and then walks into the kitchen and
seems perfectly normal in there and then
as he gets out the back of the kitchen
he takes off the apron he's in overalls
and then suddenly drops down to the
sewer and he kind of goes along a bit in
their overalls looking like a sewer
worker and then pops up the top takes
off his overalls is in a perfect suit
ready to go for a meeting somewhere to
get a package and then has to do the
reverse to get back in so it protects
your anonymity by encrypting everything
in lots of layers sending you in an
unusual routes that you wouldn't
normally expect
and then avoids being sort of seen on
the normal servers in the normal way by
doing that so yeah so basically that's
by in teaser analogy there come interact
with just a normal world or you can talk
to the spies is that a good way of
thinking of it yeah it can do either the
secret stuff that's on tour or it can do
the normal stuff that's on the normal
web and so people often say all the dark
web that's a place where bad things
happen and that's not what it's designed
for the fact that it's anonymous means
that bad things can happen on it more
easily but you can do good things on it
Whitney have more anonymity so it's
slightly safer perhaps to go and do your
online banking in a public cafe if you
encrypt it all
first and there is HTTP which is secure
HTTP and that's one way of making more
secure but then you could also wrap it
in onion layers and send it often so
suddenly you're sort of more safe in a
public place and doing something that's
you want to do more privately so is it
dangerous is a question of what you use
your anonymity for rather than that it's
specifically designed for dangerous
things because people anonymous they can
do things which are less illegal perhaps
although there's some known flaws if if
the onion web and there's ways of
tracking what happens if you carefully
synchronize events that happen the
different stages and you can also if you
view things like flash over the tor
browser that breaks all the ideas of it
because it's this built in different way
so when you log into torrid sensor say
don't use flash because that will give
away your location but if you do this
normal stuff they're not we fine and but
there are people who use it to put on
pages so there's things like the Silk
Road which is people knew about which is
a place where people could sell them buy
drugs because you were more anonymous so
the people could host the website and
what anonymous me and all the people
could go and visit in on anonymously so
it's a legal activity that's been
facilitated by anonymity there's lots of
positive things that could be
facilitated by anonymity so people who
are in oppressive areas can browse the
web more anonymously they can
communicate with people more honestly
and so on so let's bring it all back
together and talk about the difference
between the Deep Web the dark web the
web and so on so the Deep Web was just
an area which is fairly normal of the
web for such as behind passwords or just
not found the dark web is a part of the
Deep Web or it's a different copy of the
web really which specifically tries to
hide itself with talking a secret code
it's wearing camouflage and it's hiding
as much as it can to be different and to
be out the way away from Google and so
then that just makes it private so the
physical Internet of computers is the
kind of physical connections all the
computers attach together that have IP
addresses each one of those physical
computers can have a web server on it so
they can talk in
software and share information and pages
and so this is the web the deep web is
just parts of it which people can't get
to easily and then the dark web is like
a copy of the web that talks in just the
different ways to different languages
we need to start with the basics of the
web in the internet because most people
confuse those as well as confusing the
Deep Web and the dark web and how the
different and we're just going to try
and figure that out today